welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's villains are party
crashers who never
really leave sometimes because they make
the party better sometimes because they
lock themselves in the bathroom and
charge you to use it but here's the
thing marvel has confirmed more of these
past villains to return in upcoming
titles
zemo from civil war as the villain in
the falcon the winter soldier and the
real mandarin coming in shang chi
they're even bringing back jaime fox
electro from the sony verse into the mcu
spider-man 3.
and when you run down this list most of
marvel's past villains are perfectly set
up to return
even the losers we haven't thought about
in years so i'm gonna break down
the 30 forgotten marvel villains and
explain where we might see them next
and this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build you a beautiful online presence
and run your business
okay let's start with the villain we'll
never forget actually thanos
the ultimate big thick bad of the
infinity saga
and a dude we did see die twice but you
know the rule guy dies once no questions
guy dies twice
how many times are we going to go
through this if boom we can't get fooled
again
and with avengers end game splitting the
mcu into a multiverse of timelines
theoretically alternate timeline
versions of thanos still exist
like in that timeline loki just escaped
into
now it seems doubtful that we will see
the adult conqueror brolin thanos again
anytime soon but
there has been speculation that we will
see a young thanos
origin story as a subplot in the
eternals film i broken down how that
could be a very cool way to explore the
genetic history of the mcu but let us
jump back to the beginning
the 10 rings in the mandarin the
terrorist network behind raza reappeared
in iron man 2
iron man 3 the all hail the king short
and even ant-man
and then radio silence but tony liang is
playing the true mandarin in shanghai
which is going to be a martial arts
tournament movie that i've speculated
could lead to a beyonder battleworld
secret wars event
then from the first hulk film
thunderbolt ross came back for civil war
infinity war end game and now
it seems black widow leading many of us
to think that he is destined for his
turn
as red hulk either in the she-hulk
series maybe a future avengers film but
also
still alive from that film is
abomination emil blonsky who in 2017
kevin feige confirmed remained
locked into prison somewhere same goes
for the leader samuel stearns last seen
with his cranium bulging out
likely being set up as the tall domed
head of the intelligentsia feige was
asked about him
in a post-in-game reddit ama and he
suggested that no
character is forgotten and that also
goes for justin hammer
he vowed to dance back in the mcu one
day
i'm gonna make a prompt for you i'm
gonna be seeing you again real soon
he did make a brief cameo at seagate
prison and that all hail the king short
and his company's weaponry cameoed in
luke cage on netflix
which i don't think is mcu canon it
would just pose some glitches in the
matrix with cornell stokes aka blade and
mariah aka pissed off civil war mom but
with iron man 2 we got to talk about
ivan vonko
whiplash he almost certainly croaked in
that self-destruction blast to the
biodome but
there had been some stretch theories
that his
russian background could tie into
natasha romanov's past
natasha daughter of ivan because he
knows your daddy's name
i didn't daughter of ivan could have
just meant daughter of
generic russian name or even a nod to
the father figure from the comics ivan
petrovich bezukov who did return as a
creepy incesty cyborg in the comics
really that theory of whiplash being
natasha's dad is a retcon i don't think
anyone wants
now we do know loki is returning after
avengers end game and his own disney
plus series next year but he's not
forgotten and he's not really even a
villain at this point he's just more of
a bad boy but on to
red skull that retiree keeping that nine
to five as
soul stone keeper on vormir and infinity
war in any game earlier this year ross
marquand stated that the directors
confirmed that after the soul stone is
claimed red skull
is free to roam and that he might return
to earth with a vendetta or become a
godly observer intervening
when called upon but i guess it would be
kind of cool to see red skull return in
other ways like that superior being plot
with adam warlock in guardians volume 3
more on him later and yes we do know the
falcone winter soldier is bringing back
zemo in an apparent plot to assemble
dark avengers replacement team in the
thunderbolts along with
spoiler warning for this disney plus
series because this isn't official yet
bachrock the leaper with george st
pierre showing up in set photos perhaps
a member of that thunderbolts lineup
next
ultron we have made many theories about
in spider-man homecoming peter found
an ultron sentry head with its red eyes
glowing
which was supposed to mark ultron's
consciousness in that particular drone
now yes vision did seem confident when
he kept ultron's digital spread to the
centuries within the sokovian city
and he seemed to have eradicated the
last of them down to that last one that
fun detail was the same one cap tossed
off the ledge earlier
but whether peter's century head or a
dusty blinking server in the second
ruins i
just pray that this is the dawning of
the age of
ultron i really forced that i'm sorry
ant-man villain darren cross
yellowjacket appeared to die a horrific
death
but director peyton reed hinted that he
might have just disappeared into the
quantum realm a place he's going to be
exploring even further in ant-man 3.
if cross is still alive he's going to be
short and armed because it shrunk before
the rest of them did
[Applause]
we stop showing that please but before
we move on thanks again to squarespace
for sponsoring this video squarespace is
the all-in-one platform to build a
beautiful online presence and run your
business
are you looking for a website to sell
your wares you got some sexy phil
coulson art that the world needs to see
well you can present your work using
squarespace's professional portfolio
designs
display projects and customizable
galleries and add password-protected
pages to share
private work with clients you can auto
post your content to twitter facebook
tumblr you can also easily import from
instagram twitter and other platforms to
give your site the personal visual flair
that you want squarespace will even
sell you a url now i'm not sure if eric
vos marvelmusicals.com
is available but if it is squarespace
we'll sell it to you head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to our
custom url in the description
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website
or a domain okay doctor strange left the
door open for
mordo's return in the post-credits scene
too many saucers
which i have recently interpreted as a
mission to kill
an out-of-control scarlet witch and
multiverse of madness as opposed to
saving her
which i think will be strange's goal
additionally dormammu remains a very
active threat in the dark dimension
especially now that strange no longer
has the time stone to keep him at bay
with the threat of a tortuous groundhog
day time loop guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 left us with aisha
and adam warlock i think i shall call
him
adam preparing a comeback against the
guardians probably in volume three
if it ever happens spider-man homecoming
left a lot of loose ends with adrian
toombs vulture
scorpion matt gargan and someone's still
out there shocker
herman schultz and tombs at least is
confirmed to reappear in the sony verse
sponsey
in morbius next year now we're still
waiting to see how much
sony's sinister six plants tie into the
main mcu because you know sony and
disney marvel are separate studios for
now
thor ragnarok expanded that world with
all kinds of goofballs who could return
jeff goldblum's grandmaster was left
alive for now at least facing the sikar
revolutionaries
i'm proud of you all this revolution has
been a huge success
yay us but i think it's still open-ended
exactly what happened to hella
who appeared swept away by search her
sword but she
is an asgardian demigod and thor proved
that they can survive in space
and same goes for certain who likely
could have returned to muspelheim after
torching asgard now some theories pose
that killmonger could resurrect after
his dramatic end in black panther
just bury me in the ocean with my
ancestors that jump from the ships
with one theory being that its corpse
could be reanimated by the undersea
rival kingdom of atlantis and namor but
remember
much of black panther 2 is still
probably being reconfigured and again
marvel just take your time no rush on
that
ant-man and the wasp villain ghost was
another loose end scott's trip to the
quantum realm and the post-credits scene
was intended to retrieve quantum healing
particles to help
ghosts phase shifting condition but then
the snap happened and five years later
she's still hanging out somewhere
similarly we never really got answers on
the mysterious buyer of
sunny birch my buyers don't take no for
an answer
and i have promised results to some
dangerous people with theory speculating
oscorp roxon
hammer industries or aim the weapons
company of the late aldrich killian
captain marvel left alive yon rog and
the cree
an imperialist threat to the planet i
definitely think is coming back in the
captain marvel sequel or
secret invasion plots which the recently
announced fury disney plus series looks
like it could be setting up with
evidence of a cree skrull shadow war on
earth
i thought cree having sleeper cells was
top secret information the same goes for
the cree
zealot ronan who also promised to return
we'll be
back for the weapon the core
the woman now remember ronan dies in
2014 so any return by him
must mean captain marvel 2 fury or
whatever else he comes back in
must be a prequel story now let's talk
about brock rumlow crossbones
and hydra they appeared to meet their
end with captain america civil war with
wanda making sure he felt every second
of it
but again all the timeline medlin of
avengers endgame brought him
back along with sitwell hey elijah
suggesting some hypothetical alternate
timeline with rumlow in which hydra
believes captain america to be one of
their own
i don't know if marvel will ever return
to this idea but it is one of many
alternate cap histories i am dying to
see someday
we've also made theories about the
return of mysterio based on peter parker
stupidly failing to ask edith any
follow-up questions is this real
all illusions are down peter we also
know that team
mysterio is much bigger than a living
quentin beck remember box scraps
riva delivered that doctored footage to
j jonah jameson you sure you want to
commence the drone attack
there will be significant casualties do
it execute them all
so alive or dead the fake news illusions
of team mysterio can continue to ruin
peter parker's life for years to come
our final forgotten villain is perhaps
the one i'm most excited about
arnim zola the captain america villain
the filmmakers keep bringing back in
disembodied form and winter soldier
and a tiny cameo and end game the
screenwriter stated wanting to turn
zola into the mcu's modoc mental
organism designed
only for killing rumored to appear in an
upcoming mcu title
this would bring zola full circle with
the android body his early blueprints
intended him to live on in
if you're looking closely in that first
cap film so there you go that's at least
30 villains the mcu could revisit in
upcoming titles and that's not even
counting the new villains coming ahead
in the pipeline kang the conqueror
mephisto
nightmare gore the god butcher doctor
doom magneto galactus norman osborne
so many reasons to be afraid but hey at
least those villains are
fictional come on and talk about these
marvel theories with me on new
rockstar's official discord server by
becoming a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars subscribe to the rockstars
hit that notification bell
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
the new rockstars thank you for watching
boom
[Music]
you